good morning it is very early it's
probably about 6:30 a.m. I'm waiting for
my sister and my friend Nick who's
helping me film we are heading to CES
we're driving because we have so much
equipment most of which I haven't packed
yet so I have 30 minutes to pack wait
for my friends then we leave I only
slept for probably two hours and now we
have to drive four hours it's also
raining they're supposed to be flash
Bloods what a great time to drive to
Vegas but the problem is usually if you
fly there's delays so by the time you
end up packin driving and getting to
Vegas you know saving time so let's see
if we'll save time let's finish packing
do you think this is all gonna fit yeah
I think it'll be good buns our room do
you know what else I have yes the baby's
token I've had these for over a year
you're illegally podracing in the car I
guess so okay okay well I'm gonna have
to pass the vlog off to you what am i
doing you're vlogging right now hi I'm
vlogging you got to get a close-up of
her getting the coffee and you know like
b-roll shots okay do this picnic for
vlogging oh gosh all right it's awesome
yes okay I'm gonna vlog
with the camera sorry buddy no I'm a
water water sorry you just you just pick
it up what do you do
oh you can't live in the future no
working
we're here today
vlog door open ma'am I cry crushed it I
wanna dream yeah you're really making a
lot of stuff super happy
playtop hits here are the latest top
songs I thought these are all gonna be
trash yep let's go guys
to Vegas we go 4 hours 21 minutes it is
what times 7 49 let's see how long it
takes us to go for our first team we
have 2 hours 11 minutes left we
obviously are making
what do you think us now Pete you have
to be perfect
oh yeah be careful Yellin long there's
gotta be something over here right but
there's no coffee at the Ellen wall
after I thought about this assembly stop
your hair you have a red light in and
out just open did you then did you want
a snack I'm sorry did you want a burger
oh let's go it let's compact why is the
second time I've parked illegally today
why'd vehicle yeah pretty much ma'am and
he might be my pack so this is what I'm
vlogging with I decided to vlog with the
he a7s2 because I'm going to see yes I
really want my videos to be the best
quality that they can they can be
are you actually getting something I
don't think I want anything let's just
go
so they're basically came in here to see
you that's it
speak sister well we're some youth our
deadlines I have to be very very badly
we will be there in 12 minutes
oh we made pretty good time honestly
trivia
use my code I just need I only have
13,000 lives so you should use our dad
Jesus Steve use my dad's code he's a
Steve if you guys set up for HD trivia
okay hold on I'm Judy a no Guinea look
at this
and she hungry actually
is there a theme here what it's driving
I'm not a good driver why is that truck
is that the longer that has naked ladies
on it
Oh God I know No
okay oh they're naked ladies oh I don't
know take a peek potential are you how
to put nudes on that news truck
hey guys woman's do Vegas and we spent
how long in LA about an hour and a half
in line Fed Ex I was waiting for a
package i order a hard drive because I
wanted to back up all of my footage onto
onedrive before the whole CES trip I
also ordered some things from
Bloomingdale's which was supposed to get
shipped to my house but it was delayed
because of the weather so I just
rerouted a to Vegas that'd be no big
deal
after waiting an hour and a half for
what I thought was a hard drive the only
thing that I got was this black basic
sweatshirt that I'm wearing right now it
was crazy I was like probably should
turn the TV off while I was blogging
because it's right by the microphone so
it's almost like if I ever vlog before
don't know we are heading off to dinner
so I'm gonna be switching to my smaller
camera and leave this big guy behind how
do we already destroy his hotel room
every time we get ready it's like a
hotel room just gets destroyed with like
clothes everywhere okay well then maybe
it's all mine I hung them up I have my
different little house here organization
well I tried to hang you destroyed it
but you know the call the hangers there
are hangers there's four hangers left I
think you already use them because
you've never hang anything ever it's
long slob slob slob hello yes for doing
what going to dinner oh why do I say
it's allowed you know I'm you lighting
for the last time we're here which was
for Matt's birthday so since August they
got only
and something that we always do when we
are here is go to lhamo I think you're
gonna get tonight Jen oh my god I don't
know because they have like the ravioli
but then they have this other
okay so we just got done with dinner we
had some very extra special guests today
guys if you want to know why Scott is
not hosting HQ trivia it's because
you're in Vegas
go straight a blogging yo what up
bloggers my blogs it feels like doing HQ
accepts you hate it
except I take every aspect of it yeah
that's the difference well it's exciting
sister Percy yeah my first CES yeah wait
Vienna words no didn't they move it is
it used to be the same week don't look
it up over here this is so exciting so
how is H Cupid I mean it's a pretty you
know small little outfit I'm a huge fan
of thank you guys so much for satya hey
I have a question for ya
keely of the game award high-quality
tribute wait what does it stand for
do you know hard questions oh I like
that
I saw Austin I thought it was high
quality I honestly never even thought
about it well I don't know Hebrew Queens
well I hope you have a really good first
trip to CES my first blog it's my first
blog everybody I am us just look there
do you want to hold it you want to try
it okay so this is hot vlogging this is
Scott vlogging I should look down the
barrel here yeah this is my pressure a
vlogger sup y'all that's my dog
I had a waffle chicken and waffle
sandwich he was so bomb and it's like
chili honey sauce like oh my gosh so
bomb I'm get a video bomb we've got
another Scott yeah you know that there
is a Scott convention in makes the same
time so we're scattery brothers
looking to release my brother with some
of the better beer yeah no tired
I've actually your new these new bills
thanks to this guy Tina needs Beauty hi
you know I kind of been put onto it and
I am a little addicted but that's why
when you go
see that right there hold on please and
then if he's under the weather perfect
fit
it's a perfect fit my head this is
incredible I want to host one day
hopefully I can do you think people I
mean Jesse when you grow up when you
answer all the questions that's the
prize you get to I can't even get past
question five and I have 10,000 extra
lines like visualize it's crazy it's
pretty crazy
guys so so this is the end of basically
our day 1 vlog traveling here I don't
even know what happened but there's
gonna be a lot of stuff happening so I'm
super excited let me know if you guys
know if there's anything that you want
me to check out leave it in the comments
below
my friend bloggers leave a comment below
let me die you feel check it out liked
it share it subscribe see he's making
fun but like next week it's not like hey
guys to come I need to make fun of
myself